or christine joins me now i don't know
what i'm gonna
what you have left to say after that
governor but uh
they are they are so annoyed by you uh
why is that and why do you have a target
on your back when it comes to the
american media
you know laura i really think it's about
control they have used for the last year
fear to control people and in south
dakota we just took a very different
path
we knew the science told us we couldn't
stop the virus
we could slow it down and protect people
who might be vulnerable and make sure we
had enough hospital capacity to take
care of those who would need it
but that we were going to do it together
and allow people to be flexible to take
care of their families and still put
food on the table
so you know that was a unique approach
that for our people really worked well
we did have
tragedies and we did have losses but we
also
got through it better than virtually
every other state and i think the media
hates
that because it really is a testimony to
what republicans believe in what
conservatives believe in we we
implemented
what we always say we believe and it
showed that it really does work and
bring more opportunities to families
and governor the new york times again so
obsessed with you
that they attacked you in this video
this was just last
wednesday in gnome's world
restrictions become inconveniences that
hold companies back gnome uses words
like want and choose
on purpose she's making it seem like
she's giving you freedom
but public health isn't personal
responsibility
it's her job she's the one who's
supposed to make tough decisions
but she's offloading that responsibility
onto ordinary people
that that reporter sounds quite young
good for her but
you're offloading personal
responsibility governor is that what
your
constituents believe yeah laura i've
never seen a video
like that before that was an outright
hit piece
and it was hard to watch because it was
full of lies
you know really the truth is that in
this country when a leader
such as a governor oversteps their
authority in a time of crisis
it breaks the foundation of this country
what is the next event that it's okay to
do that in what is
the precedent that that is setting up
into the future and
i was well aware of that throughout this
last year while i was making decisions
that
i knew what my authority was and i
didn't want to step
over it and i trusted my people and
overwhelmingly
they appreciated that they appreciated
the ability to get through this
in a way that worked for them their
businesses and
our state that really was an example to
the nation
and governor noam a lot of other issues
are bubbling up out there
while you continue to make sure your
state is safe and prosperous
uh there's the talk of the battle for
the soul of the republican party the
party's divided
because of liz cheney or someone like
adam kinziger i guess mitt romney
do you think the party's divided on
ideology
or even this impeachment farce of a
trial next week
yeah i think we're talking a lot about
what we disagree on
and the i gave a speech a couple of
weeks ago
about what republicans need to do and
why the american people are so angry
with them
and it's because we don't follow through
on the things that we say we said we'd
reform health care we didn't
we said we'd fix immigration policy and
we didn't
and that is really what we need to do as
republicans and start following through
and stop standing up giving speeches and
attacking each other but instead work
together to really follow through and
pursue
american opportunity for the folks at
home but it's not what president trump
did governor i mean the america first
agenda was
wildly successful pre-covered obviously
coveted threw a wrench into everything
but
i i'm basically focusing on this this
attempt to lurch back
to the mid-2000s to much more
interventionist
open borders pro-china trade uh type of
governance
versus an america first populist
approach
which seemed to be really popular so
where's the device oh absolutely
yeah well president trump never forgot
about the ordinary
hard-working american he thought about
them every single minute of every day
and fought for them
arthur brooks told me one time to never
get angry on behalf of yourself get
angry on behalf of other people that
need help and that's what president
trump did
he he fought for everyday people who got
up and
worked long hours to take care of their
families so we do
we should not go back to what this
country was before
him and we need to make sure that we
continue putting america first
governor great to see you tonight thanks
so much for joining us
and the new